so that's the end of the introduction um
let's
now begin to drill down on the data
resources that we'll need to launch our
investigation
and there are two different kinds of
data we need to talk about the corpus
and the kb
just like any other nlp problem we need
to start with a corpus a large
collection of natural language text and
for relation extraction we need
sentences containing two or more
entities
and because our goal is to do relation
extraction with distant supervision
we need to be able to connect the
entities to a kb
so we need a corpus in which the entity
mentions are annotated with entity
resolutions
which map them to unique unambiguous
identifiers the same identifiers that
are used in the kb
so in this representation i've got the
string elon musk which is
just an english language string that's
what we call an entity mention
and then i've got elon underscore musk
which is an entity id
it's a unique unambiguous identifier for
this entity
in some predefined um
dictionary of entity ids
and it's very common for this purpose to
use something like wikipedia which has
one wikipedia page for
almost any entity that you can think of
for our investigation we're going to use
an adaptation of the wikileaks corpus
which was produced by google and umass
in 2013 the full corpus contains 40
million entity mentions from 10 million
web pages
and each entity mention is annotated
with a wikipedia url
but we're going to use just a subset of
the full corpus in order to make things
manageable
so let's start to look at some of the
code we'll use in the python notebooks
for this topic
um the data assets that we'll use live
in a subdirectory of our data directory
called relexed data
and we've defined a class called corpus
which holds the examples and which lets
you quickly look up examples containing
specific entities
so if we load our corpus we find that it
contains more than 330 000 examples
pretty good size
it's small enough that we can work with
it easily on an ordinary laptop
but it's big enough to support effective
machine learning
and we can print out a representative
example from the corpus
actually this is a bit hard to read so
let me give you a different view of the
same example
we represent examples using the example
class which is a named tuple with 12
fields listed here
uh the first two fields entity one and
entity two contain unique identifiers
for the two entities mentioned
we name identities using wiki ids which
you can think of as the last portion of
a wikipedia url
the next five fields represent the text
surrounding the two mentions
divided into five chunks so left
contains the text before the first
mention
mention one is the first mention itself
middle contains the text between the two
mentions
mentioned two is the second mention and
right contains the text after the second
mention
and the last five fields contain the
same five chunks of text but this time
annotated with part of speech tags which
may turn out to be useful when we start
building models for relation extraction
now whenever you start to work with a
new data set it's good practice to do
some data exploration to get familiar
with the data a big part of this is
getting a sense of the high level
characteristics of the data summary
statistics distributions and so on
for example how many entities are there
and what are the most common ones
here's some code that computes that
and here are the results
so there are more than 95 000 unique
entities
and it looks like the most common
entities are dominated by geographic
locations
now the main benefit we get from the
corpus class is the ability to retrieve
examples containing specific entities
so let's find examples containing elon
musk and tesla motors
there are five such examples and here's
the first one
actually this might not be all of the
examples containing elon musk and tesla
motors it's only the examples where elon
musk was mentioned first and tesla
motors was mentioned second
there may be additional examples that
have them in the reverse order so let's
check look for tesla motors elon musk
sure enough two more examples in reverse
order
so going forward we'll have to remember
to check both directions when we're
looking for examples containing a
specific pair of entities
okay a few last observations on the
corpus
first this corpus is not without flaws
as you get more familiar with it you'll
probably discover that it contains many
examples that are nearly
but not exactly duplicates
this seems to be an artifact of the
web document sampling methodology that
was used in the construction of the
wikilinks dataset
and it winds up creating a few
distortions and we may see some examples
of this later
but even though the corpus has a few
warts
it will serve our purposes
just fine
one thing that this corpus does not
include is any annotation about
relations
so it could not be used for the fully
supervised approach to relation
extraction because that requires a
relation label
on each pair of entity dimensions and we
don't have any such annotation here the
only annotations that we have in this
corpus are entity resolutions mapping an
entity mention to an entity id
that means that in order to make headway
we'll need to connect the corpus with an
external source of knowledge about
relations
we need a kb
happily our data distribution does
include a kb which is derived from
freebase uh freebase has an interesting
history it was created in the late 2000s
by a company called metaweb
led by john gianandrea who
later became my boss
google acquired meta web in 2010
and freebase became the foundation of
google's knowledge graph
unfortunately google shut freebase down
in 2016 which was tragic
but the freebase data is still available
from various sources
so rkb is a collection of relational
triples each consisting of a relation a
subject and an object
so for example place of birth barack
obama honolulu has spouse barack obama
michelle obama author the audacity of
hope barack obama
so as you might guess the relation is
one of a handful of predefined constants
like place of birth or has spouse
the subject and the object are entities
represented by wiki ids it's the same id
space used in the corpus wiki ids are
basically the last part of a wikipedia
url
now just like we did for the corpus
we've created a kb class to store the kb
triples and some associated indexes
this class makes it easy and efficient
to look up kb triples both by relation
and by
entities
so here we're just loading the data
and printing a count of the kb triples
uh there are 45 000 kb triples so this
is quite a bit smaller than the corpus
if you remember the corpus
had 330 has 330 examples
and we can print out the first kb triple
so this is a kb triple that says that
the contains relation holds between
brickfields and kuala lumpur central
central railway station which i did not
know
just like we did with the corpus let's
do some data exploration to get a sense
of the high level characteristics of the
kb so first how many relations are there
the all relations attribute of the kb
contains a list of its relations and it
seems that there are 16 of them
well what are the relations and how big
are they
this code prints prints out a list with
sizes um note the
get triples for relation method which
returns a list of the kb triples for a
given
relation you begin to get a sense of
what kind of stuff is in this kb
it looks like the contains relation is
really big with more than 18 000 triples
and there are a few relations that are
pretty small with
fewer than a thousand triples
here's some code that prints
one example from each relation relation
so that we can form a better sense of
what they mean
some of these are familiar facts like a
joins france spain
others might refer to unfamiliar
entities so for example i've never heard
of sheridan lethanu
but i think you can quickly form an
intuitive sense of what each relation is
about
now one of the most important methods in
the kb class is get triples for entities
which lets us look up triples by the
entities they contain
so let's use it to see what triples
contain france and germany
okay sure they belong to the a joins
relation that makes sense
now relations like adjoins are
intuitively symmetric so we'd expect to
find the inverse triple in the kb as
well
and yep it's there
but note that there's no guarantee that
such inverse triples actually appear in
the kb there's no guarantee that the kb
is complete
and you could easily write some code to
find missing inverses
now that relation adjoins is symmetric
but most relations are intuitively
asymmetric
so let's see what triples we have for
tesla motors and elon musk
okay they belong to the founders
relation good that's expected
that's an asymmetric relation
what about the inverse
elon musk and tesla motors
okay they belong to the work dat
relation
seems like a funny way to describe
elon's role at tesla but okay
so this shows that you can have one
relation between x and y
and a different relation that holds
between y and x
one more observation
there may be more than one relation that
holds between a given pair of entities
even in one direction
so uh for example let's see what triples
hold uh what triples contain cleopatra
and tomali the 13th theos filarap fillo
phillo patter
oh my goodness this pair belongs to both
the has sibling relation
and the has spouse relation
to which i can only say
moving right along
let's look at the distribution of
entities in a kb how many entities are
there and what are the most common ones
well here's some code that computes that
there are 40 000 entities in the kb so
that's fewer than half as many entities
as in the corpus if you remember the
corpus has
95 000 unique entities so there are lots
of entities
in the corpus that don't appear in the
kb at all
but just like the corpus the most common
entities are dominated by geographic
locations england india italy and so on
note that there's no promise or
expectation that this kb is complete
for one thing the kb doesn't even
contain many of the entities from the
corpus and even for the entities it does
include
there may be possible triples which are
true in the world
but are missing from the kb
so as an example these triples are in
the kb founders tesla motors elon musk
worked at elon musk tesla motors
founders spacex elon musk you might
expect to find worked at elon musk
spacex but nope that triple is not in
the kb
that's weird
well in fact the whole point of relation
extraction is to identify
new relational triples from natural
language text so that we can add them to
a kb
if our kbs were complete
we wouldn't have anything to do
now actually in this case you might
object that we don't need to do relation
extraction
to make that completion we could write
some logic that recognizes that um
founders x y entails worked at y x
and apply that rule systematically
across the kb and use that to fill in
the missing triple in this case but the
general point still stands that there
may be lots of triples that are true in
the world but missing from the kb
where that strategy is not going to
allow us to to add the missing
information